joining me now is the shadow policing
Minister Sarah Jones Sarah Jones good
morning Tim thank you for being with us
on Sky News I mean first of all I just
want to get your response to the latest
information that we've had that a formal
identification process is ongoing and
how Lancashire police have handled this
well I think as we're all thinking this
morning our thoughts have to be with the
family those two little girls
and we must let the police get on with
the job of identifying the body and
establishing what happened I think
questions about
what may or may not have gone wrong with
the investigation come after that it's
certainly true that there was an unusual
amount of information put into the
public domain it's also true that there
was an unusual amount of speculation and
debate on social media about what had
happened to Nicola the the information
commissioner is looking at this to see
what
was released and and why and the police
themselves will do an investigation as
they would with any kind of major
high-profile case such as this but I
think for the time being we need to
focus on the family and letting the
police get on with the job of
establishing what happened in such uh
awful circumstances that that may seem
to have taken place yeah absolutely
right the family must stay at the center
of our thoughts in all of this but I do
Wonder Sarah Jones if you could think of
any justification as to why those
personal details were released by the
police last week well we don't know the
what we going on behind the scenes we
don't know what
confronted with we don't know what
information they felt they needed to
release and and why and we don't know
what the family involvement in that was
so it's pure speculation just as it was
speculation uh that that everybody has
been
watching on social media over the last
three weeks as to what actually happened
to Nicola bully so there will be a time
for questions about this for sure but
but the time is is not now we need to
establish is that you know exactly what
happened and uh support the family
yeah I mean it's been described by some
as victim blaming do you understand why
people some people are seeing it that
way
well certainly there has been a history
in cases of for example violence against
women where uh it's been a historical
problem where the kind of misogyny
within uh the system has meant that
victims have been blamed for the crimes
against them that is nothing new but I
think until we understand what the
motivation was and what was happening
here we can't rush to judgment it would
be wrong to do that
um and I think we must just focus on
what's happened to Nicola and let the
police get on with the job at in hand at
the moment
but the public will need to have
confidence in Lancia police I mean they
were told to improve last year
by a report I mean what kind of
confidence do you think the public can
have in this particular Force at this
moment well we know that across
country confidence in policing has
dropped in large part I think because of
the lack of resources in our local
communities people don't see police
officers as much as they used to they
don't feel that if they report a crime
anything will be done if you're burgled
you phone the police they don't
necessarily come there are some wider
problems here about police confidence
because of all of the cuts that we've
seen from this government what labor has
said is that violence against women and
girls in particular has to be a real
focus of a labor government and will be
and putting police officers back on our
streets thirteen thousand officers that
we've committed to and pcsos on our
streets visible preventing crime will
will play a large role in building that
confidence and we've also seen across
the country issues with standards when
it comes to vetting and misconduct and
the awful cases we've seen of the murder
of Sarah everard and the case of David
Carrick so there is a lot of work to be
done that labor will do around national
standards for vetting and misconduct to
boost confidence in policing and make
sure we have the right people policing
our streets but in this case I think we
need to wait until we have all the
information to hand and at the moment we
simply do not now we don't of course no
evidence that there is any violence
involved in this particular
in this particular case but I do wonder
what would a labor government do to try
and make sure that families get the
support and do you think that this
family has been supported in the way
that it should have been
well again we don't know we're not there
behind the scenes neither you or I know
what has gone on of course we need our
police to be resourced well enough to
support victims and again
family support
and support for victims has been found
wanting under this government and we
need to focus on victims and families
all the way through the process of these
kind of cases the the number of people
who go missing and the resources that
the police have to deal with that is it
is a real issue that we do need to
address and we do need to make sure the
police are supported to do the job that
they need to do this is being a
particularly high profile case and it is
particularly agonizing and and we just
have to feel for the family
and Sarah Jones uh just before I do let
you go of course uh one of the other
main stories that will be uh in the news
this week is the efforts by the prime
minister to try and get brexit finally
sorted it was reported in the papers
yesterday that sakir Starman will offer
labor party support to any brexit deal
that comes back what's that going to
look like
I think one of the frustrations we've
felt
in the negotiations on Northern Ireland
has been that the negotiation is not
really between the UK and the EU it's
between the Prime Minister and his own
back benches and we saw with the
intervention on helpful intervention
from uh Boris Johnson that that there is
a a war going on amongst the back
benches and uh the government and that
must not be where the focus is so we are
saying do not focus on that focus on the
people of Northern Ireland and what is
good for our country and if you get a
deal on that basis where we can move
forward with all the parties in Northern
Ireland where they can be given the
space to look at the deal and to come to
a conclusion and we move forward
together then we will support the prime
minister to make sure a deal can get
through Parliament if that's what needs
to happen we have to focus on what is
good for the people of Northern Ireland
and what is good for the people of this
country not the Rouse on the back
benches of the conservative party
okay Sarah Jones Shadow policing
Minister appreciate your time this
morning thank you thank you for being
with us